Narrator: Commercial kitchens
from our favorite restaurants
and fast-food places
produce some of the toughest
and thickest grease.
If left uncleaned,
it can cause serious
damage to sewage systems,
health risks from contaminated food,
and even kitchen fires.
Here's how some of the greasiest parts
of restaurant kitchens are
professionally deep cleaned.
Jay Lopez, the owner of Cleannex,
walks us through how his team
cleans a restaurant's
kitchen exhaust system,
which extracts the fumes from the kitchen.
Jay: Today, I'm going to
be walking you through
how we clean the kitchen
exhaust system in a restaurant.
The purpose of a kitchen
exhaust system is to
extract the fumes from a
kitchen in a commercial setting.
In order to remove grease,
you have to understand grease.
What holds the oil together is the fat,
and once the first layer is up,
it becomes a magnet,
and it attracts more and more and more.
Everything is cleaned from top to bottom,
and you will start cleaning the fan first.
We're using a high-end degreaser
with a little potassium
hydroxide and sodium hydroxide.
Those two chemicals
combined create miracles
in destroying the fat and the grease.
In our case, we time it somewhere
between 10 to 15 minutes.
Once we see that the
grease starts to melt,
at that point we know we
need to apply hot water
and remove it, because
anything longer at that point
is going to start to destroy the metal.
Once the fan has been cleaned,
the next step would be the duct.
That's the part that
connects the fan to the hood.
This level is considered extreme.
That was a fire waiting to happen.
I would say this is about
a year worth of grease.
It all depends on the volume of cooking.
If this is moderate cooking,
this is about a year's worth of grease.
That's a lot.
The duct is cleaned in
a few different steps.
During this process, we use
a tool made by Guardian.
This tool is known as the
EZ magnetic duct scraper.
It has magnets set into the tool
and a razor blade on each side.
Once it's clenched to the duct,
it is manually moved forward and backwards
until the grease is removed.
This forward-and-backward method assures
that the grease buildup will
be removed from both sides.
It'll go from the yellow color
all the way into the black.
When it's in the black level,
that's an extreme level.
That means that the system has
not been properly maintained.
In these types of designs,
we'll use duct spinners and duct brushes.
The duct spinner is
designed to self-rotate
within a protective cage and
spray water at high speed,
which dislodge buildup
from the metal duct.
We use a combination of a
foaming agent and a degreaser.
The foam is used as a delivering agent,
and it allows the degreaser to stay
in contact with the grease
for a longer period.
If foam was not used,
the degreaser would drip off the grease.
The next step would be
the hood and the filters.
See, the filters are your
first line of defense.
What the filters is doing
is holding back heat,
and it's holding back most of that grease.
When the filters no
longer can hold the grease
and once that grease starts
getting heat and melting,
you have the potential of that grease
dropping into your food.
And at that point, it's a health issue.
I've seen restaurants been shut down
by the health department
for not cleaning their hood.
I've seen restaurants been shut down
by the fire marshal for not
maintaining their hoods.
We take precaution in protecting the area
from contamination.
We use two layers of plastic sheeting
in order to protect the appliances
from coming in contact with any chemical.
The second layer of plastic sheeting
is wrapped around the hood,
and then a funnel is created.
The funnel is used to drain
the chemical, grease, and water
into the plastic containers.
The plastic sheeting also
serves as a protective barrier
in preventing the chemical
from coming in contact
with the food-preparation area.
Once we're completed and the
plastic sheeting is removed,
we'll conduct a freshwater wipe-down
and recommend to the client
that they do the same
prior to preparing any food.
According to NFPA 96,
which is the agency that
regulates this industry,
the frequency of cleanings
depends on the style of cooking
you're conducting and
the frequency of cooking.
For example, if you
cook with solid fuel --
solid fuel is basically
cooking with charcoal --
those are 30-day mandatory cleanings,
because they produce a lot more grease,
and the embers that
come from the solid fuel
can ignite the grease.
If you're an occasional cooking facility,
those would be a year.
Narrator: Maurice Patterson, who co-owns
MMP Environmental Solutions,
walks us through how
he cleans a grease trap
in a restaurant kitchen.
Maurice: Today we will be
cleaning a commercial grease trap
in a Mediterranean restaurant.
The function of a grease trap
is to prevent any solids,
fats, oil, and greases
from dishwasher or dishwashing sinks
from entering your piping system.
So, the cleaning process typically starts
with me inspecting it,
making sure it's functional.
Typically, you want to
clean your grease trap off
every three months.
I would say that it hasn't been serviced
most likely close to a year.
Then we unplug the grease trap,
and we start to remove all the components.
From that step,
we will prepare them to be
cleaned with a pressure washer.
So, right here we're doing our pump-out.
We have the wand connected to
the high-powered vacuum pump.
We'll use the wand to pump
out the entire grease trap.
So as you can see, there's a lot of grease
sitting on top of the grease trap,
and you can get a glimpse of solids
that have floated to the top as well.
For Mediterranean restaurants,
you're going to get a
lot of oils, cheeses.
You're also going to get a lot of rice.
The rice is usually the main contents
that sink to the bottom of the grease trap
that you're going to want
to pump out regularly.
I would describe it as yellow grease.
So, yellow grease is
typically grease that's used
to make fries or things like that.
There's actually two
different types of grease
known in the industry.
You have brown grease.
That's typically grease that's scraped off
from pots and pans that's traveled down
into your dishwasher and your
sink down to your grease trap.
And then you also have yellow grease.
You can actually sell it certain places.
They may recycle that grease
and turn it into biofuel,
things like that.
It's considered liquid gold.
Some companies, I'll
actually pay them for it,
so they're incentivized to make sure
that it's not going down the drain.
Here, what I'm using is a putty knife.
I'm scraping just old food waste
that has collected on there.
Organic waste just turns black over time,
gets oxidized and turns black.
It's a health risk, mainly
because any type of overflows
from your grease trap may
come in contact with food.
We use a pressure washer just to make sure
we're getting all the
residual solids cleaned out.
I'm using steel wool just
to do a final scrub-down,
make sure I'm getting into
all the nooks and crannies,
all the tight spaces.
I do this right before
we do a final spray-down
with the pressure washer.
So, we dispose of the grease
at a water-pollution-control facility
that will accept the
fats, oil, and grease.
And there's not many
places that do accept it,
so it's limited,
but we dispose of it in an
environmentally responsible way.
When grease goes down the drain
with the dishwater, it's typically hot.
So, grease or oils, when
they're hot, they're liquefied.
When they cool down, they
solidify in the drain.
That may cause plugging,
which will in turn cause
backups, overflows.
If it negatively impacts
their sewer system,
then they can incur fines.
They will have to buy a new grease trap
or pay plumbing fees to
rectify the problems.
Narrator: Steve, the
owner of Superior-Clean,
walks us through how he cleans
a commercial exhaust system.
Steve: We begin the cleaning process
by removing the kitchen hood filters
and wrapping the exhaust hood to ensure
that we properly contain
all of the greasy water.
We'll start at the upper ductwork,
where the grease accumulates the most.
The top of the ductwork
here is where the grease,
the smoke, and the heat exits.
The purpose of cleaning
the upper ductwork first
is to ensure that we properly flush
the entire ductwork back
into the kitchen hood.
So, our goal as a certified
hood-cleaning company
is to ensure that all accessible areas
of the hood and ductwork are bare metal,
meaning there is no grease left over
and there's no possibility
of a kitchen fire.
So, the way we start degreasing the system
is with a high-foaming agent,
and we can mix in sodium
or potassium hydroxide
to strengthen up our mix.
From there, we will
scrape down the ductwork
to ensure that all the
thick grease is removed
before we come back and hit it
with high-pressure steam cleaning.
So, what you're seeing here in
this fast-food establishment
is the fatty grease that are being pulled
into the exhaust system,
and it's very watery.
Much different than you'll
see in Chinese places
or steakhouses that have
more of a carbonized grease.
Steakhouses are generally built-on carbon.
Chinese places, you have
extremely thick, gooey grease.
We typically see with wok, peanut oil,
it becomes a very rubbery substance.
It's almost like a
rubberized Gorilla Glue.
It's extremely difficult to clean,
and it requires a lot
of scraping, degreasing.
It moves down vertically
to a horizontal 90 bend,
and that's where the
inline exhaust fan sits.
To the left of the system,
there are two access panels,
which gives you the
accessibility to scrape,
degrease, and steam clean
inside of the ductwork
to make sure that the
system remains bare metal,
and that leads you into the kitchen,
where the exhaust hood is.
Exhaust fans are generally
the dirtiest part
of the kitchen exhaust system
due to it being the last point
of passage before it exits.
We just finished off with steam
cleaning the upper ductwork,
which flushes the grease
down through the inline exhaust fan,
and now we're moving to the inner blades.
So, what we're looking for
when applying the degreaser
on the exhaust fan blades
in the ductwork is the foam.
Once you start to see
that the grease is turning
into a yellowish tint of
a color and it's foaming,
you know that you are able to hit it
with the hot-water pressure washer.
The temperature of the
hot-water pressure washer
allows the grease to really soften up,
and it moves a lot easier
than trying to do with a
cold-water pressure washer.
Now that we have flushed
the entire ductwork
back into the kitchen,
we are able to apply a low-pressure,
high-steam rinse of the kitchen hood.
So, the opening to the
ductwork in the hood system
starts behind the hood filters.
The way we clean this is exactly
as the rest of the system.
We do not neglect any areas of the duct.
This needs to be degreased,
scraped, and steam cleaned.